let's get into like the sticky and talk
about vaccines oh we're gonna go there
we have to go there
there's too much about it
there's too much curiosity there's too
much awareness coming out about it you
know one of my colleagues and good
friends in the medical field is Dr
Robert Sears he is two exits down the
freeway from me you know we're really
close in proximity and really close uh
as spiritual companions through this
life and he said it best recently and
he's always in trouble so you know I I I
do try to avoid topics that are like
you know the Hot Topic because there's
there's persecution you know like like
one of the things I want to talk about
is like the the burning of witches and
it's like no this this is still the
burning of witches here and so we we
share a lot of common clients I call
them clients some people will call them
patients and what he said is that um in
his practice he's been practicing
Pediatrics for 25 years
she has released a book called The
vaccine book he's done a lot of research
and he has a client base where when he
started the majority of his clients were
questioning some you know vaccine
choices
um and and then as his practice evolved
everybody kind of saw him as the the
pediatrician that would accept them you
know a lot of Pediatricians if they're
controlled by the insurance companies
will say hey we can't see you in our
office like you need to find another
pediatrician and so he was the
pediatrician with open doors that said
you know I'm here to welcome you with
the choices that you're making for your
children as a responsible adult making
autonomous choices based in best
benefits risks and Alternatives and here
are those benefits risks and
Alternatives and what he found is that
most people these you know decided not
to adhere to the CDC
you know it's different there's it's
it's it's always changing but the
recommendations that change every year
and what he saw is that in a practice
that should have had a lot of children
that were really sick from diseases that
we're vaccinating from were were
children that were actually really
really healthy and if they did contract
some of these you know pertussis
whooping cough type things that their
immune systems were able to support them
in a way where they yeah they got sick
but they none of them had died
so statistically speaking it doesn't
really line up and so he you know he
what he also has seen on the contrary is
people that have come to him because of
injuries that have been had and he's
watched those children recover and then
parents make choices outside of what
they did the first time because they had
seen an injury and you know pivoted to
not have the same experience for future
for future children and so it's just one
of those
um
things that if we we look at the numbers
with you know and granted it's a small
pediatric practice but it still is is
it's relevant and it it's you know and
and like I said we share these clients
and so a lot of people choose home birth
because they don't want to have the same
experience that they had before which
could involve injured children for
someone because it's got to be a
personal decision intuitive do what
feels right for you go do your research
like where would you point where would
you point what direction would you point
people in to do that research to make
that decision for themselves yes so it's
definitely a personal decision and it's
something that I always say like always
always use informed consent while making
those decisions like it's not a
one-size-fits-all medicine in general is
not one size fits all it should always
be individualized
um Bob is a really good place to start
so the vaccine book you can get on
Amazon
um him and one of my former clients
Melissa Floyd did a podcast called the
vaccine conversation I think it's the
vaccine conversation.org I'll have to
double check on it but they have hours
and hours and hours and hours of
recorded information
specifically we could even talk about we
there's a bill coming up in California
that's going to require all 13 year old
boys and girls to get the HPV vaccine to
enter school and so they had a big
conversation about the benefits risks
and Alternatives of the HPV vaccine so
there's just a lot of movement within
that right now and it's it's really
you know like it's it's it's pretty
censored
um and so there's you can definitely
find information out there but you have
to to look at the right places so I I
would think the vaccine conversation
podcast would be the perfect place to
start
did I hear something when I was
listening to some things prepping about
still bursts and an increase in
stillbursts in recent time
so the numbers aren't out all the way
yet but what we're starting to see is
anywhere uh up to an increase of
stillbursts of 1700 since 2020. nobody
knows I mean people have their their own
conclusions but there's nothing that has
been you know in the medical community
that says this is what's causing it also
last week
uh we had our release of information
about maternal mortality so there's
infant mortality and maternal mortality
and maternal mortality went up 40 from
2020 to 2021. 40
there's a lot of
um medical racism if you will there's
there's disparities within different
communities that the you know the I
think it's 42.8 per 100
000 women that die or black compared to
12.1 that are white
um don't quote me on those exact
statistics but I think that's what it is
um and there's so many different ways
that we can look at this but
40 and 17 years
like are you kidding me easy numbers
they're crazy in numbers and and you
know like our infant mortality rate Cuba
has a better infant mortality rate than
the United States what is going on is
there really population control going on
is there like what the is going on
because
things are not sensical like these are
incredibly scary statistics I mean you
know you hear you know Bill Gates say
that we need population control and then
you hear Elon Musk say we are running
out of like we there's not enough people
yeah we're gonna we're this is a problem
and I can see it from that side because
I mean here I am I'm 40 like I'm not
having children like women are having
them later people are generally having
less kids I think yeah there's men have
men are have more erectile dysfunction
have a lower uh fertility rates I mean I
think the testosterone Ray has dropped
70 percent yeah like that's a
significant huge thing there's a doctor
that talks about the the um shrinking of
the perineum the taint is what it's
known as and every year that the space
in between our as women are perineum in
between our vagina and our anus and then
as men in between the testicles and
their anus is shrinking every year
there's actually something called micro
penises now micro penises like don't
come across one thank God but you know
well it but you know I have in my
practice like I had my ultrasound tech
message me and be like this penis is
really small and I was like shut up like
what are you talking about and I mean
the baby came out with a micro penis and
this is a mom that takes really good
care of herself so where where is that
coming from you know like like is it the
Plastics is it the the phytoestrogens is
it the glycipate that's being sprayed
all over every freaking thing even if
you eat organic you know it's in
everything uh the seed oils that were
like what is it what is it you know
there's It's a combination of all the
things is it one thing who knows
now before we get off of totally
um children I thought I just wanted to
ask about circumcision one of the topics
that I am most passionate about actually
when I worked in the hospital I had an
office next to the newborn nursery
and I remember the first day that I
heard the scream of a newborn baby boy
that was being circumcised it printed to
the depth of my soul I will never forget
it it still makes everything in my body
every every ounce of my soul stand up
and say that I will always be the voice
of newborn baby boys that don't have a
voice
so let's look at World circumcision
rates right we are we are barely anybody
circumcised in the world like we're at
80 of the world that's not circumcised
okay you're 40 I'm 41. when we were
growing up right everybody was
circumcised I mean if you had like one
friend I had you know a friend John who
was from Argentina he wasn't circumcised
and everybody knew everybody in America
for sure yeah everybody knew that there
was one friend who had a baby and she
you know the other day she came home a
couple weeks ago and because he got
circumcised that day and yeah yeah so
now in the United States that's that's
as a whole the United States has dropped
under 50 for circumcision
um in the western states in the western
states we're right around 20
um because a lot of insurance companies
are not covering it because it's now
being dubbed a cosmetic procedure
because it is okay so there is no
medical benefit the American Academy of
Pediatrics sticks their head in the sand
they actually posted a graphic when they
release their circumcision statement
probably 15 years ago and it was a bird
with its head in the sand okay stop it
yeah so what we know is that Dr Kellogg
Kellogg cereal brought circumcision to
the United States back in the late 1800s
and a lot of and sugar for
breakfast well yeah among a million
other things right and what he said is
that this there's this puritanical
belief system that if we circumcise eyes
boys they wouldn't masturbate back then
they thought that masturbation led to
Insanity okay so the basis I mean I know
there's religious reasons I get that
like I'm not not talking about that okay
the basis of westernized medical
circumcision is based on the Assumption
of Dr Kellogg who told us that guys
wouldn't masturbate now we know that's
not true right like come on like
they're not we're not talking about
Kellogg's cereal are we yeah okay yeah
okay I was like wait a second I heard
Kellogg and there's one picture okay
yeah so Dr Kellogg brought this
information in now we could go into the
spirituality of this right if we are to
take a newborn baby boy out of the arms
of a brand new mother and take it
somewhere and cut off the most sensitive
part of its body
right there you have just dubbed control
of that mother in her parenting
relationship right
like let that sink in like like it is so
unmaternal to let anybody harm your baby
but to have a medical professional come
in and say that you have to to do this
and cut off the most sensitive part of
its body that right there asserts
control within the medical system
immediately if you like this clip and
you want to hear the whole episode click
at the bottom of your screen